welcome back to trump watch and in this  latest episode of a thing i just  invented we are looking at the  investigation of sy vance the prosecutor  in manhattan  who is looking into the trump  organization and the trump finances  and according to reports dance is  talking to a lot of different people not  only michael cohen  who southern district of new york  federal prosecutors have talked to seven  or eight times now  but also the ex-daughter-in-law of alan  weisselberg the cfo of the trump  organization  and according to the new york times  cybants has subpoenaed the personal bank  records of weisselberg  himself and our scrutinizing gifts he  received from former president trump now  of course this may never amount to  anything but that is a lot of interviews  that is a lot of  effort being spent if there's no there  there so it's entirely possible that we  will see members of the trump  organization  in court just like i'll see you in court  if you don't subscribe